there's a lot of poor performers
especially in LA I think they have kind
of ascended out of porn and they've kind
of transitioned to like social media
stars and become more accepted I think
yeah you're totally right people look
down on a porn star or like oh yeah I
could watch him on my phone but I would
never date one exactly they've been with
look how look how many dudes she's been
in gang bangs and all this other stuff
but what they don't consider is that
probably any guy or girl in any
nightclub in LA has probably been with
10 times more people that we're not
we're not tested for STDs prior to
having sex with them right but it's the
conception of the fact that you can see
it you can literally watch it happening
and to me that is like that is kind of
that's kind of like categorizing women
into two groups like one is the just
it's just a wifey material
you know like she's yeah and eight and
bring home to your mom right there's
this girl in porin and you're like no no
she's a [ __ ] but still again as I'm
saying behind closed doors you're still
gonna watch her you know right right oh
like that's that's being a hypocrite
totally yeah do we go back to what I was
talking about the girls that have like
reached gotten out of porn like they did
it for so long and became so successful
they kind of like piqued interest of
people like oh I have an Instagram or I
have a Twitter you can follow me on my
own platforms yeah and they've kind of
like become social media stars and and
they make those uh those only fans
accounts yeah so they kind of control
everything that's kind of like the way
media that media industry is going I
think anyways because people who are
creating are creating their own content
now and being in charge like they own
their own stuff and they're able to
monetize it yeah their own way instead
of being a slave to some porn producer
or a porn agent that's just sending them
across the country to go live in some
producers house for a week
you know all I have to shoot 10 porn
videos yeah for sure I think that's
that's another you know that's a
direction where we're headed for sure
but I wouldn't count out the the shitty
producers and the amount of people that
will still be attracted to that cuz
you're still gonna have people who are
not you know they're not able or they're
not in you know during a desperate
situation they don't have time for
Instagram you know what I mean so it's
like too many people is actually about
survival as well yeah yeah but I mean
yeah we're gonna see we're gonna see I
think we're gonna see to some extent
we're gonna see that happening for sure
more and more yeah when you talk about
aggress what do you mean when you talk
about aggression or violence and porn do
you think that's something that is like
ramping up or getting more prominent I
mean we I mean if we're gonna look at
the studies that we have we've kind of
seen that trend for years you know it's
not really you know aggression important
it's not that new I wouldn't say that
but yes I mean of course it's gonna be
like I've talked to producers explaining
to me that they actually they get bored
is one guy was like yeah like of course
we're gonna you know look at like how
extreme can we make it because like it's
not only the consumer that gets bored we
get bored as well so yeah but like when
it comes to aggression important it's a
thing and it's very like going back 15
years the aggressive porn would have
been like the strange point like the you
know like the dark web porn kind of but
now that is mainstream so I would say
like that is kind of shifted like what
has shifted is it's just the acceptance
of aggression important and the fact
that now we don't even think of slapping
someone or pulling someone's hair ass
aggression really you know that's just
part of porn so you know the boundaries
are constantly being pushed but
they're also constantly being ignored
yeah yeah there's almost no boundaries
anymore it's like blurred lines in
between both for sure yeah I think there
was a quote from a porn producer saying
that the only thing left to do to women
in porn now is just you know killing
them like that's with genitals yeah and
there are important on that too you know
it's not porn that's the thing - yeah
what is it what is it wasps wasp after
they mate the female eats the male
that's next for humans yeah oh the
spider yeah that's what it is yes yeah I
mean if it's one thing if it was I mean
porn is legal yeah there's a lot of
drugs that people use because they're
hard to get and they're illegal and it
becomes more of a desirable thing
because it's harder to get corns not
hard to get everybody can get it so it's
interesting why there's still such a
problem with people being addicted to it
but there's there's no real there's no
real alternative there's nothing else
like it that you can say is healthy
right or isn't bad for you
psychologically right exactly and that's
you know I would say like the whole like
the existence of porn like - the amount
of you know yeah that we do see today I
would say that is really like a slap in
the face to any you know any country
lacking sex education because what we do
see in studies also is that kids and
youth tend to look for porn when in fact
what they're looking for is is fact you
know they want sex education mm-hmm so
that's you know that's that's a signal
to all of us to step it up when it comes
to sex education because you know you
know the situation we're dealing with
now is that we've gotten we don't you
know you know sex education is really
like like this you know it's not really
it's not the same like if I look at
Sweden it's like we have some some parts
of Sweden who is doing a really good job
and then you have
the parts you aren't even talking about
condoms so you know what I mean it's
very Russian roulette when it comes to
sex education and I think that really
leaves kids and youth alone with porn
that's the only sex educator so that's
when we got to ask ourselves okay so if
this is our sex educator if this is our
teacher
what kind of would mission does this
teacher have you know what's the purpose
with curriculum is this teacher using
and so on so yeah yeah the problem is
there is not there is no goals or
anything it's all about just more more
money for them their goal is not to
provide kids and youth great sex
education that is not what most point
producers are about you know they're
about the money as you're saying and
another thing to consider is that a lot
of young people probably mostly young
girls look up to people like Pam
Anderson or Carmen Electra as like oh
look at them now they're celebrities
mm-hmm right like they're they're big
shots now they're not porn they're not
porn stars anymore so I could just be a
porn star for a few years and then I
could have the goal of being like Pam
Anderson one day yeah for sure
and that also I mean that's that also I
think speaks to where we're at today
when it comes to the normalization of
pouring because it really is so you know
right next to mainstream media mm-hmm
I think it used to be more separated you
know but now it really is transitioning
from porn to mainstream media you know
it's not that hard so what's the answer
to this Maria you tell me what is the
answer I'm as I'm saying in my TEDx talk
as well I'm really all about like
education and conversation I think that
is just key like if we get to have a
conversation and be critical and really
like look at this from a fact point of
view I would say that is gonna bring
some solution to this because I do think
I do think like getting people aware
will then enhance her ability
chose to make an informed decision so I
mean I I'm not gonna and I can't do that
I can go into your bedroom and be like
I'm gonna stand here and watch and make
sure you don't use some pouring you know
and I'm gonna be a little night like I
can't do that so and I don't want to do
that so what I can do is I can provide
you with the facts and then it's up to
you do you want to continue to use porn
then fine go ahead or do you want to
like consider these facts and you know
make an informed decision but yeah so I
think facts and education is key and to
really like bridge the gap between the
adults like how you know parents are
thinking about this they perhaps some
are very aware and some are like no my
kid is 15 and he or she has never even
like kissed someone you know like the
gap is perhaps too big sometimes to kind
of bridge that and then the sex
education in school need to you know we
need to step that up for sure and then I
would say - and I'm doing that and I
want to do that more to actually connect
with people in the industry to actually
see what are the pull factors and what
are the actual the backgrounds and what
I'll do you know the reality porn yeah I
think that yet the younger years the
hardwiring years I think are the most
important years - and it's big you know
a big part of the responsibility has to
go to the parents on it - because a lot
of parents they just are lazy or that
they don't if it makes them
uncomfortable they're gonna resort to
being lazy and they're just not gonna do
anything about it right and I mean I
think we can kind of like it I can
identify with that like if something
isn't comfortable obviously it's gonna
like my brain wants to opt out of that
task or whatever you know but yeah so I
mean this is gonna take an effort from
all of us for sure but I actually think
like equipping parents with facts and
getting them to really understand like
okay so first my kid is going to see
pouring maybe not tomorrow but pressure
like that is going to happen should like
you know that reality check of it and
then also to to equip parents - like
you're saying like - dirty
the conversation